The Business That Would Evolve Into Taco Bell
Started Out Selling Hot Dogs
In 1946, Glen Bell left the Marine Corps at
the age of 23.
Like many of his comrades, he was looking
forward to post-war activities and settling
into a career when he returned home.
Luckily for him, the fast food business was
booming, and Bell had an idea: a hot dog stand.
It was called Bell’s Drive-In, and it was
set up in San Bernadino, an agricultural town
in California.
Bell didn’t know the first thing about running
a hot dog stand, but that didn’t matter;
he learned as he went along.
The first stand did well and when Bell sold
it in 1952, he was able to go on to make a
bigger, better stand that sold both hot dogs
and hamburgers.
At this point, Bell wasn’t exactly thinking
outside the bun.
He did manage to start up his second stand
before the McDonald brothers announced their
fast food venture—also in San Bernadino.
You can probably guess how it went, since
McDonald’s is still selling burgers and
Bell’s business isn’t.
It was likely because of the increased competition
that Bell started to explore alternative menu
options.
Feeling the pressure to stand out from the
crowd, Bell did start “thinking outside
the bun” and landed on Mexican food.
A big fan of Mexican take-out himself, he
thought that Mexican food lovers needed a
fast-food option, as people often had to wait
a while to get a good taco on the go.
So, Bell began scheming.
In his own words,
My plan for experimenting with tacos was to
obtain a location in a Mexican neighborhood.
That way, if tacos were successful, potential
competitors would write it off to the location
and assume that the idea wouldn’t sell anywhere
else.
With his new location secured, Bell began
with what he knew—hot dogs.
Both regular hot dogs and chilli dogs were
on the menu, and the chilli dogs had a secret
sauce on them that would later become the
basis for the taco sauce we know today.
While those were selling, Bell was researching
tacos and coming up with ways to produce them
quickly.
Many Mexican food restaurants stuffed the
shells, then fried them, which was partially
why it took so long.
Bell decided he would instead fry the shells
and then stuff them, meaning he could have
fried shells ready to go before the customers
lined up.
It took a while to work out all the kinks,
but Bell soon hit upon a deep fryer that suited
his needs.
At the taco’s debut, they cost 19 cents
each (about $1.61 today).
According to Bell,
I’ll never forget the first taco customer
because naturally, I was really concerned
about his reaction.
He was dressed in a suit, and as he bit into
the taco the juice ran down his sleeve and
dripped on his tie.
I thought, ‘We’ve lost this one,’ but
he came back, amazingly enough, and said,
‘That was good, I’ll take another one!’
Business was booming.
Bell ended up opening another stand in Barstow
that sold tacos and shakes, and a few years
later he opened three stands dedicated to
tacos, which he called Taco Tias.
Obviously, it didn’t end there.
Bell became more and more ambitious.
Even when the three stores started raking
in $50,000 a year each, he was happy to give
them up for the chance to expand into Los
Angeles.
The move was risky; Bell bought two lots to
build restaurants on, but in doing so he became
strapped for cash.
To solve the problem, he ended up partnering
with a few of the L.A. Rams footballers who
trained near a Taco Tia and loved the food.
Together, they were able to build several
stores and make a profit in their first year,
quite the accomplishment for a single restaurant,
let alone a few in their debut.
The restaurants were called “El Tacos.”
However, Bell wanted a business that he solely
owned, so he built essentially the exact same
restaurant, but re-branded it as “Taco Bell”
in 1962 in Downey.
He followed it up with eight other small Taco
Bells on Long Beach.
He then set about franchising his restaurant,
with the first Taco Bell franchise purchased
in 1964; this first franchise, run by an old
L.A. policeman, did unbelievably well, and
the owner was reportedly bringing in around
$10,000 per month (around $74,000 today) almost
right away.
After that raging success, it’s no wonder
that people were clamouring to own a Taco
Bell.
A mere three years later, in 1967, they opened
their 100th restaurant in Anaheim.
Just three years after that, the company “went
public” with 325 restaurants in 1970.
What had once been a tiny hot dog stand had
evolved into a huge Mexican fast food company
in a little over a decade.
Taco Bell celebrated its 50th anniversary
in 2012, two years after the death of its
founder.
It now boasts some 5,600 restaurants, 350
franchisees, and over 150,000 employees.
Taco Bell almost started out as a mini-golf
course.
Thinking about what people might want to invest
in after the war, Bell thought they might
want to return to fun pre-war activities like
mini-golf.
However, he didn’t have quite enough money
to run a golf course, so he opted for the
hotdog stand instead.
A man named Ed Hackbarth was employed to run
the second taco and shake stand in Barstow.
He went on to found Del Taco.
The popular “Taco Bell Chihuahua” was
featured in many Taco Bell ads from 1997.
Her name was Gidget, and she became so popular
that they started making toys in her likeness.
When they stopped using the dog in 2000, revenue
dropped by 6%, the largest decrease in Taco
Bell history.
It’s thought that they stopped using Gidget
because she was portrayed as a stereotype
which was upsetting some Latin American communities.
Gidget was euthanized at the age of 15 after
a stroke in 2009.